you
there was an important moment I think in
our background about 10-15 years ago
when we designed Casa La Rocca in
Caracas why I like that project still
out of all of the work that I don't like
is that it expands on a very simple
principle that was laid out you know
centuries ago by Jefferson in the
serpentine wall in Virginia the idea
that through a certain economy of
folding or bending you can bring
structural stability to a wall that's
only one with thick something that was
later radicalized by alladia gesture our
contribution to this lineage was very
simple if you don't think of the wall as
a brick wall but start to think of it as
a wall within which the mortar sets the
agenda of the wall the mortar not as a
fixed entity but as a variable entity
through the renovation of a bonding
system that is not fixed like a running
bond or Flint Flemish bond but rather a
variable bond you can bring different
densities of structure into this wall
that has lateral bracing but in that
moment you bring to the space behind it
the possibility of controlling light and
air the idea that a structural
proposition acquires an environmental
gain or if you like a social gain the
division of the inhabitants of that
house from their in-laws next door to me
that's a moment where problems of
materiality culture technology and the
environment coalesce in a very specific
design move and what I like about that
also it's not so much interested in the
design of a wall it's interested in the
design of the parameters that gauge that
wall so that once you understand that I
can give it to you as another person to
redesign it for me or
to cultivate a relationship with it
which is much more intimate
you know our work is is constantly about
failures you test things so that they
fail that's the way engineers progress
they they build arches test them to
their yield point and I hope somehow to
be able to do that not in the technical
realm so much but rather in the in the
realm of synthesis yes we have learned a
lot about those from those failures
maybe if I can say the biggest lesson
I've learned from ourselves is in the
quest for determination and
specification we probably have focused
too much on the role of a single detail
in its ability to proliferate and
control an entire design and and the
transition from let's say the design of
an object to the design of parameters
that engage objects has been our most
successful lesson now when I sit down to
design and I design much more
collectively now with other discipline
groups I am still invested in the
peculiarity in the specificity of an
architectural object but I'm much more
interested in what the other discipline
groups can bring to it and the degree to
which my engagement with them can
specify the parameters that propel the
design process and in turn the object
but it gives us more lateral freedom to
produce new forms of knowledge to
incorporate others in it and to make it
smarter